I'm afraid we're going to take you
across to Brussels yen stoltenberg
yesterday's explosion in the east of
Poland on the border with Ukraine
our top military commander General
Cavalli briefed allies
and the Polish Ambassador updated us on
the instant and the ongoing
investigation
yesterday's explosion took place as
Russia launched a massive wave of Rocket
attacks across Ukraine
since the start of Russia's illegal war
in Ukraine
NATO has increased vigilance across our
Eastern flank
and we are monitoring the situation on
continuous basis
and investigation into this incident is
ongoing
and we need to await its outcome
but we have no indication that this was
the result of a deliberate attack
and you have no indication that Russia
is preparing offensive military actions
against NATO
our preliminary analysis
suggests that the incident was likely
caused by a Ukrainian air defense
missile
fired to defend Ukrainian territory
against Russian cruise missile attacks
but let me be clear
this is not Ukraine's fault
Russia Bears ultimate responsibility as
it continues its illegal war against
Ukraine
in the meeting today NATO allies offered
the deepest condolences on the tragic
loss of life
they expressed their strong sovereignty
with our valued Allied Poland
and made clear that we will continue to
support Ukraine in its right to
self-defense
Russia must stop this senseless War
last night I spoke with the Polish
president Andrei Duda and with president
U.S President Joe Biden
we agreed that we need to stay vigilant
calm and closely coordinated
we will continue to consult and monitor
the situation very closely
NATO stands United and we will always do
what is necessary to protect and defend
all allies